[Music]
[Music]
I like you better without the Beretta I
feel naked without it
do you have a condom what do you have a
condom
why why what because we're about to have
sex
totally I mmm it's just not it's not
something I know when they worry about
so you're just gonna slide in here and
we were gonna have sex without
protection well yes I just Bob James
it's not it's good when we do it
together
look I know who you are and I know your
reputation as a sleek spy who always
gets his man yeah that's the thing
you've slept with every woman you've
come in contact with No okay look so
unless you're silly gadget watch can
suddenly make them condom appear no sex
no problem mmm - its bond I need
assistance
it's an emergency right yes the mission
it's going fantastically listen I I need
something I there are guard dogs
everywhere now as is my training I can
drug dogs with condom I need a male sex
condom sent to me not for sex but Cheers
good job Thanks oh you know what I
realize there is a Carlin behind the
face of my watch so I do have one oh
really yes
watch condom
[Music]
see that look it's so thin you can't see
it
Wow secret government Finn thank you
appreciate that
let me just having trouble putting on
your invisible condom
it's a long journey from the tip to base
maybe we should set up camp halfway
build a fire I have great beans oh my
god I'm not buying any of this without
watch scan me for STDs large impressive
scanning for STDs negative except for
HPV which no biggie so even this fake
reality that you're creating you still
have HPV I wanted it to be believable Oh
God
listen to me no condom no sex actually
you know what I changed my mind
no sex I just really want to do this
move where I shake it but I don't stir
it you know sorry it's not happening
come on it's just a common thing maybe
sweet romance oh is it romance that I
felt when you snuck in here like a
British ninja master chunk up against my
butt perfect I'll do you in the butt no
what do the tits you masher and there's
a canal and where the technique
you're not gonna happen I'm done
showering what about a dry hump but
we're naked so it's like a moist cuz
you're on me and I get the porch all
sloppy but I don't go in the house 60o
you want me to roleplay I'm just a boy I
have a retainer that I'll take out
before I go down stop we're done you can
see yourself out ya know what I will see
myself out
no use wasting this masterpiece watch
dispense lubrication
you
[Music]